Jerez pretty critical of the coaching
staff and the things that happened in
the game do you ever think sometimes
when he says those things that under
Kingdom they're kind of messages that
you guys have for players again we just
got to focus on coach as well as we can
and playing as well as we can and
they're feeling there were some things
in the game that we have to get better
at and we're gonna work on that as a
staff and as a football team but again
our eyes are forward on Buffalo s Jason
Garrett meeting with reporters on Monday
he was asked a very specific question
Chris do the things that Jerry Jones
said and we talked yesterday at length
about the criticism of the coaching
staff directed by Jerry Jones does it
undercut what you're trying to do Jason
Garrett didn't answer that question he
didn't answer it which tells me what the
answer is the answer is of course it
undercuts what I'm trying to do what can
he say that's one of the reasons why
he's had that job for so long sure he's
had that job for so long Chris because
he lets Jerry be Jerry he lets Steven be
Steven they take up all the oxygen in
the room he just coaches the team they
don't want a Jimmie Johnson they don't
want to Bill Parcells they don't want
somebody's gonna come in and say just go
sign the checks and leave me alone I
know what I'm doing and it's worked
until you know what happened the Joneses
built a team that actually is really
really good and now the coach is the
weak link and they're beside themselves
because the coach isn't able to get the
most out of this talent that they've
accumulated that is Super Bowl worthy
yeah a hundred percent and therefore
that goes back to the back to the Jones
family on that one a little bit I mean
you know but you're right the Jones
family is built to mean an unbelievable
Super Bowl team I mean just break it
down right Mike I mean if you're just
gonna talk about the Patriots there's
the Cowboys the other day you know okay
who's got the better offensive line
Cowboys the runningback Cowboys
quarterback hey it's closest available
deck Prescott's in the prime of his
career I'd probably give him the edge
right now you know just as far as right
now the second defensive line Cowboys
linebackers okay close maybe the edge to
the Patriots maybe it's very close to I
mean we know that's a special line back
in court with the Dallas Cowboys
secondary Patriots again but it's close
I mean the the secondary in Dallas is
real I mean there has
really been a game this year where
Dallas can't walk on the field and go
our 22 is the better 22 on the field and
that does not reflect well on the
coaching in general and that's the issue
and that's why the Jones lamb was going
crazy Jerry Jones will appear on 105 3
the fan in Dallas later this morning if
he hasn't calmed down from Sunday that
could be very significant to Jason
Garrett immediate future here's Stephen
Jones who was on 105 3 the fan in Dallas
on Monday talking about what the mandate
and the expectation is the rest of the
way certainly do set it off set it you
know we want to take the next step this
year and we certainly can still do that
snow first place in our nation we've
gotta grow much you know get on a run
right now and make the plays that we
need to make them but when the games
that we need to win to win our division
and then we've got to go have success in
the playoff okay let me interpret what
Stephen Jones just said first of all
they got to make the playoffs or Garrett
is gone second of all they got to have
success in the playoffs or Garrett is
gone green and third of all Chris when
he says we got to go on a run right now
I'm telling you if the bills beat the
Cowboys on Thursday national audience
America's team on America's holiday
losing to the team they beat
back-to-back years in the Superbowl to
start that run of glory back in the
early 90s if they lose that game and
they get embarrassed they get out
coached in the process I think Jason
Garrett Black Friday for him isn't gonna
mean go buy a bunch of stuff it's gonna
mean pack up your stuff and get the hell
out I think it could happen Friday if
they get beaten by the bills and
embarrassed by the bills and out coached
by the bills on Thursday I'm not saying
that's gonna happen on Thursday but if
it does I know what I'm gonna be doing
on Friday I'm gonna be paying close
attention to any and all news coming out
of Dallas because I think he could be in
trouble
as soon as Friday I agree with you that
they're gonna they have to make a
playoff run to save his job I'd really
do think it's come to that point where
they're gonna have to win one at least
one may I really probably two games it
might as the way it looks right now I
would go and the Cowboys aren't in the
NFC Championship game
he's in trouble you know - the other
thing is you know I don't know if I
agree with the Black Friday thing just
because hey they are still winning the
division and they are still a team that
if they can get in the playoffs they're
dangerous because of all the things we
talked about earlier in the segment
they're very talented they're big and
powerful and they can they can dominate
the line of scrimmage up front so
there's things that translate to playoff
football the last thing is we spent so
much time to last three even four weeks
talking about you know the cowboys and
the Eagles the the down the stretch you
know schedule and things like that
you know here we are a few weeks later
and now the Eagles have the easier part
of the schedule you know they got
through it as far as the Seahawks and
Patriots and they lost both but Dallas
did nothing to separate themselves and
now you look at the two schedules and I
go what Dallas has got a harder schedule
than the Philadelphia Eagles this is
trouble I mean they got the Bears the
Rams the bills like you mentioned
they're all still there on the schedule
you know you look at the Eagles and I go
whoa dolphins Giants Redskins Cowboys
Giants they're gonna walk they're going
four and one down the stretch here so
the pressure is on Dallas to win some of
these football games and you know some
of the teams they're playing got good
defense isn't gonna be a pain in the bud
and let me tell you I think if the
Eagles weren't in the midst of such a
bad season relative to what we expected
from them Garrett may already be gone
because the fact that the Eagles have
been so bad relative to what we expected
yeah the Cowboys are still in pretty
good position but it may not be great
position and and I also think that if
they're gonna make the move and they
know they're gonna move on from Garrett
there may be some wisdom given given
Chris Rashard an opportunity to drive
the car before they make a coaching hire
because maybe he's the answer and if he
can turn it around if he can get more
out of this talented team down the
stretch maybe he coaches the way into
the job for next
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports